question is what is the number one
problem facing men today and what is the
number one problem facing women today
I'm gonna say something come on
the number one problem answer all the
questions come on top the number one
problem with men is that they don't tell
women the truth and the number one
problem with women that get caught they
can't handle the truth simple oh that's
a good that's a good Paradigm to start
from because it's actually very
interesting you say that a lot of women
say I just want a man who's honest and
then the second you're honest she's like
what you did it wrong it's like well
then don't ask me for honesty of course
I [ __ ] lie thank you so that's a good
that's a good point I agree with that
one I don't think it's the biggest
problem but it certainly is a problem in
relationships today that is a problem
the biggest problem with men today is
that I think the world is becoming hyper
competitive most men are not aware and
understanding of how quickly there's
going to be a genuine shift in between
those who have things and those who do
not have things not just finances but
also females status everything else and
it's a status game right and it's
becoming harder and harder for men to
play
and that's all women's fault of course
because no it is because women choose
the winners right women choose who the
high status males are so
women pretend to give a [ __ ] about men
of course they don't they give a [ __ ]
about themselves and and a woman and a
woman and a woman a woman if you ask her
what she wants from a man she's like I
don't want much I just want to find a
nice man who's a millionaire and six
foot tall and funny and charismatic and
interesting and spontaneous and looks
after me and doesn't cheat and and it's
funny and good looking and strong I
don't want much like they name all this
[ __ ] that most dudes are never gonna
have and it's becoming harder and harder
and you end up with people
top G's who own everything on the planet
they could ever possibly wish for and
then you've got other guys who have
nothing and there's this large divide
there's no longer any Middle Ground you
have dudes who can't get any [ __ ] and
then you've got dudes who are just
blocking girls off right and center and
that's what the problem with being a man
is today what about the women
well everybody
shut up and have my Clementine no
no I'm from you sir you want to learn
from me well I wanted to answer I feel
like it goes for both it's not just one
of the other I feel like it's
self-accountability
definitely women are not accountable for
themselves I agree with you there why
just women though
there is both you're right but Society
punishes men for not being
self-accountable but Society does not
punish women for not being
self-accountable I'll give you an
example if you're a man and you're
arrogant and you think you're something
when you're not trust me Society will
teach you very quickly that you don't
matter when you don't get laid and you
stay [ __ ] broke if you're a chick and
think you're something when you're not
you can run around with your ego still
get dates still get laid still have a
fairly
sensible social life society as a whole
doesn't come along and slap you in the
face with realizations if you're a man
and you think you're something you're
not it is a ticking Time Bomb until
Society teaches you a lesson that's the
difference this is why men in general
are more self-accountable because the
men who are not self-accountable get
[ __ ] up so those who are successful
are very self-accountable people they
look at themselves and go okay the only
way I'm going to get and progress
further the reason she left me the only
way I'm going to do better make more
money etc etc is I have to change most
women don't want to do that they don't
sit and think I have to change they
think oh he left me because it's him and
I lost my job because my boss and this
is this because of this they've not your
women don't look in the mirror and
change your [ __ ] thing no because
don't forget what you're forgetting
right nowadays they can't change it
because it's all about body positivity
a size 28. are you saying lizzo's not a
10.
are you guys trying to get me canceled
see I'm not gonna
I said because 90 percent cosmetic
surgery is is by women women are trying
to change as much as possible men don't
want to change they're not accountable
for themselves they think that because
because they're a man you're going to be
attracted to them no like you can you
can't be fat you stay at home you're
just playing video games and you expect
a woman to want to [ __ ] you no she's not
going to want to [ __ ] you yeah but then
she won't this is the point and and and
then she won't and Society will teach
them a lesson they might be able to pull
off a little blag with a girl for a year
or so but in general they're gonna end
up lonely in general they're going to
struggle to find Partners I agree with
you this with the cosmetic surgery thing
women are happy to change out their
appearance and change how they look but
they're not happy to change how they act
most of them they're not happy to change
them no they're not the women are
changing what the men don't care about
the men don't care about the big old
lips yes they do no they do it the women
are doing that for themselves yeah
because the men don't care about it the
men would rather a woman change your
stinking attitude
then put on all that makeup and hair and
everything that's what the men want but
the women I go out there like oh I'm
gonna change this I'm going to change
that if you look at a man and a man said
yeah he's fat the man will most well if
he's feeling bad about himself he wants
to make that he'll go and hit the gym
what's someone going to do go and do it
get a BBL get her lips done put on her
makeup put on her hair and stay in a big
old fat person that she is and say oh
it's body positivity the men don't even
want that the women are not getting all
this cosmetic surgery for the men
they're getting it for themselves you
can't turn around what man wants a woman
that gonna turn around don't have an
operation they can't sit on a plane
because her ass has been injected or
been interfered with she's got a lie
there on her stomach you think the men
want that or wake up in the morning
before you gotta hit the house she's
gonna put on I'm sure I worried about
some of the men because they must go out
with a woman and then when they wake up
in the morning they think who the hell
is she the Sky by the time you take
everything off women need to change
their attitudes before they change their
makeup I'm sure that it even more than
that change your attitude because women
have got there and they would want to
change this they want to change that all
the things that don't count if you learn
to the same way how women can got that
lunch but make up learn to cook learn to
wash by hand learn to please that's what
you need a girl
she's right for who I'm saying it's like
you're we had literally just talked
about this off camera when we when you
guys picking up from the airport we were
talking about oh what what's the value
system or the point system for a woman
who cooks versus a woman who can suck
good dick and [ __ ] well but you like
cooking something because what I'm
saying is is that Pearl you can crave if
I'm wrong but um quoting her was that
when she interviewed people on the
street that there was more points given
to something like a sexual return as
opposed to oh wash this is my hand
there's a dishwasher why cook we can eat
out there's a chef people don't get they
don't give a [ __ ] about that that's what
they think but we literally just talked
about this yesterday no it was okay I
did a street interview and I asked the
guys would you rather have a girl that
gave good head or a good cook and most
guys they want this but I think that's
for the quick satisfaction I think
that's more for like a one night stand
but what I'm trying to say is that if
you all the women out there and they're
talking about well some of the women
want to be settle down they want a man
right and you've got to think what the
man wants the man they're interested in
that look at when you when you're doing
Street interviews you're in during
single people
look at the people there that are
happily married and ask them what they
do because all the things that the women
out there doing you can be a housewife
you can be going out you can suck okay
just as good as any old [ __ ] on the
street and keep your man and have a man
I'm not going to say that because I'm 32
years in counting Auntie you can't say
you can't say attraction is not
important though it is important
initially exactly you a man is not not
going to find you attractive and then
think oh because you you can cook well
it's got a chef a man's gonna find you
attractive and he's okay let's let's ask
Andrew
be with a girl that's five out of ten
because she can cook that ain't what I
said oh firstly that's not what she said
to be fair and the secondly I'd be with
a 10 out of 10 who can cook because I'm
top jeep but to make the point I think
what you have to understand is what men
are looking for in a relationship so you
did the the street interview and you're
asking single people probably young
people probably idiots you know they're
on camera talking [ __ ] about good head
all this garbage [ __ ] what men are
interested in in life not just in their
relationship but in their life as a
whole is status I don't think most
people understand especially women how
competitive the male world is and how
competitive it is for status this is why
men do everything they do men buy the
faster car not to drive any faster
because of status is why we want a
bigger house we don't give a [ __ ] where
we live it's because of status that's
why I want to go to the gym and get big
and strong because of status everything
we do is about status it's why I want
the better jobs so I want more money so
I want to be respected so what's the
number one thing we want our female to
give us status that's what we want so
she can give us status by being
beautiful that's one thing she can do
but another thing she could do is if I
turn up home and I come home with my
boys and she says I'll cook you all a
steak that's status that's all my boys
going Ross you just been out all night
and she's here and she's going to cook
for all of us and she'll clean up and
tidy up boom that's the kind of girl a
man's not going to want to lose because
it makes him look good
status suck a dick blah blah blah listen
it can only be sucked in so many ways I
mean I know let's be serious about this
because you had the three thousand no no
no no this is actually a serious point
right this is a very serious point
because the Western world has collapsed
in real time and it's a failed Society
one of the reasons is a failed Society
is because of the over sexualization
especially of females as a whole if a
woman comes up to me and goes I'll be
the best sex you ever had I am [ __ ]
revolted I don't want the best sex I've
ever had I want you to be pure and a
virgin you should know what sex is cook
my [ __ ] dinner shut up don't come and
talk to me about [ __ ] sucking dick
it's vile it's disgusting I don't want
to hear that [ __ ] can I say something I
don't want to hear that [ __ ] what I want
is a woman that makes me look good no
woman who's running around talking about
sucking dick can make me look good so I
lose interest completely and utterly and
that's the truth so what she's saying is
completely correct these are old school
things but it's not about the ACT yes
you can order food of course it's about
the status that comes with it that's
what it's about uh Sagittarius spoken
like a true one that is true
well as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible